so thanks
to be here today so like
Ron said you
I've worked for about eight years in
digital marketing and strategy and
there's so much happening in the space
you know when I first joined Weber every
two years we would re-evaluate our
offerings and what we were doing and
then it seemed like okay we're
rethinking things every month and now
it's like every six months were
rethinking what we're offering and
everything that's on the screen right
now we could spend the entire 50 minutes
talking about any of them but today I'm
gonna pick five of these that I think
might be relevant to Yale sort of
holistically and I'm gonna talk about
them at a pretty high level because of
the amount of time that we have so I'm
going to move pretty fast
and I will get you out there for your
drinks in time this is actually my
second time presenting here so last time
I came I spoke about content marketing
and how do you operationalize a content
marketing team and the biggest piece of
feedback I got was that I was speaking
too much from a corporate lens and not
enough for how things could be applied
at Yale so at the end of every section I
have a couple of thoughts starters on
what these trends might mean for Yale
and hopefully a few of those land and
resonate with you if not happy to answer
questions at the end so the first thing
that I want to start with today is a
story about stories and this very much
the titleist presentation is digital
trends new now and next this is very
much a now category not something that's
coming next this is really something
that we are considering a new best
practice that everyone has got to
grapple with and have a really strong
handle on and when I say stories I don't
mean narrative and storytelling
I mean stories as a technical format for
conveying content so one of the ways
that I know that I'm getting really old
in this space is that I now work with
people who have no recollection of whole
eras of the internet that were like
vital to my career and I think this is
something that is about to fall into
that category when I deal with some of
the interns and new people that that we
hire if you think back 10 years ago when
smartphones were just achieving some
kind of a critical mass of penetration
in the market
everyone was thinking about how you do
video on smartphones and everyone was
doing what they always do with a new
technology they were taking the old
format the old conventions from film and
TV and broadcast and just slapping them
into the new format and as a result we
have a lot of people really awkwardly
flipping their phones to view things
sideways unfortunate incidents when you
know the sides of content is getting cut
out and it's very much a not native
format of a video for the platform fast
forward to today times have changed
whereas 10 years ago people would not
have even thought about filming content
vertically and in fact I've had many
conversations with film production
people where they don't want to shoot
content and vertically because it is so
against the aesthetic that they were
trained with now people are very much
embracing that as a format overall
people people are spending huge chunks
of time on mobile more so than desktop
more and more every year and you know
this is the stories are becoming the
true native application of video on
mobile and just looking around I'm
guessing that everyone has a pretty good
idea of what I mean when I say stories
but just in case stories are a video
format that combines video components
emoji overlays typography additional
graphics into a series of static and
moving images that tell a story and just
a quick little example of what they're
like this is one that Honda did this is
actually very simple as far as stories
go you know it's just one video there's
a few different overlays the emojis are
planning a key role some of them can
actually get quite complex and the story
about stories is that this is something
that started with snapchat this was the
one of the key features that snapchat
used as a differentiator against other
social networks Facebook Twitter
Instagram that it was competing with
Facebook stole the format they
integrated it into the core Facebook app
most significantly they made it a key
piece of in
to Graham's functionality that's one of
the things that caused Instagram to
explode in popularity over the last few
years at the same time they kneecapped
snapchats growth and we're able to keep
them as a second tier competitor rather
than someone who could truly steal a lot
of market share from Facebook but
Facebook isn't the only one that has
taken it Twitter has a version of this
whatsapp has a version of this and we
think about across messaging platforms
and social platforms the use of stories
is exploding
last year in their q4 reporting
Instagram reported that on a daily basis
half 500 million of their 1 billion
users we're using stories on a daily
basis so they're either creating stories
themselves or they're interacting with
stories that their friends have created
so when you think about what you the
types of content that you need to be
sending out into the world to reach your
audiences stories is very quickly
becoming one of the dominant forms
across all social platforms and so very
quickly what could this potentially mean
for Yale if you are in charge with
running communications programs that
reach out to students or prospective
students that a hundred percent means
mobile and video and at this point I
assume most people know that those two
things are vital to any communications
campaign aimed at a younger audience but
it also means stories if you're just
doing LinkShare posts or graphics or a
traditional video you're missing out on
a huge opportunity to talk to these
audiences in a native way and you really
need to start thinking about how you're
going to experiment with stories over
the next year I think when people first
see stories the and and process what
they are they go towards this place of
thinking of stories as just a new
evolution of fast snackable content for
a generation that has a shorter and
shorter attention span and I don't think
that's actually correct certainly there
are some applications that fall into
that realm but if you look at what news
organizations are doing on Instagram on
Facebook on snapchat
institutions like Vox are doing really
interesting things taking the the
ability of stories to string multiple
different content pieces together so
think opening with a title card moving
to a video moving into a graphic of some
kind moving into a typographic statement
back to a video and they're actually
finding really engaging long-form uses
for stories where you can talk about
really complex topics through a content
format that maybe you weren't quite
thinking would be able to you know to
bear that much information so when you
think about how you might use stories
this year don't just think about you
know students and brand affinity and
raising awareness and short really quick
snappy things think about how it might
also apply to longer form more complex
topics that you want to convey but you
want to get out to audiences on all of
the different channels not just in a
written text or the types of formats
that you would usually think of for
long-form live streaming is the new
social so like when I got into digital
marketing and advertising and strategy
it was the golden era of blogs so I'm
very much of the techno utopian
democratization of everything not that I
believe any of that anymore after the
last two years but I think what we saw
happen was as blogging and those
technologies faded social came onto the
scene
you have Mark Zuckerberg talking about
the the way that Facebook and social
facilitates community building and
gathering and I think we've all seen
that that is not actually true in a lot
of instances lately but one of the
things that I'm really interested in is
the way that there are some new
applications of live-streaming that may
actually be able to bring back just a
little bit of that that hope that there
could be a true you know community
platform enabled by technology so before
we get into what that actually is some
background over the last year streaming
and over-the-top delivery systems for
media have started to surpass pay TV and
broad
cast in terms of total number of
subscribers if you look at the growth of
cord cutters and court Nevers these are
people who have either gotten rid of
their traditional TV and cable packages
or have never actually had cable and TV
packages because they're getting it all
over the Internet
these are continuing to grow and these
types of streaming applications are
becoming the dominant way that people
get but we have traditionally thought of
as as programmed televised media and so
these these platforms are starting to
gain a majority share of the market over
the traditional vehicles at the same
time they're also starting to dominate
creatively so last year was the first
year where the streaming services Amazon
Hulu Netflix actually commissioned and
produced more TV shows than all of the
broadcast networks combined so we're now
at a place where the dynamic has
completely flipped and you know
streaming is now the dominant and
natural way that people are taking in
that type of media social platforms are
seeing this it's been no secret that for
a really long time
Facebook's goal from an advertising
perspective has been to steal away the
dollars that would traditionally go to
television and realize that as its own
revenue we've seen over the last year a
number of platforms Facebook Instagram
all trying to launch their own version
of streaming television and if you take
a look at total number of users which is
what this chart shows right now it seems
like they're winning there's more people
who are streaming and watching that type
of program plus pure raw user created
live streaming than on Digital streaming
subscription services TV networks or
site apps or even gaming applications
but this is all a lie actually this data
is fuzzy Facebook would love for you to
believe it's true but it's only part of
the story even though they have more
people by volume than
some channels I think the future of live
streaming isn't necessarily going to be
the social platform it's going to be
twitch it's going to be places like
Netflix YouTube Hulu they're actually
getting a lot more time and engagement
with these audiences than the Facebook's
and the instagrams of the world and
twitch in particular I think it's poised
to dominate in this space not
necessarily on the programmed media side
but on the raw live stream user created
side so for those of you who don't know
what twitch is twitch is a live
streaming platform that's available on
all devices it's made its reputation on
the back of eSports people who play
video games professionally go on play
each other stream them themselves
playing these games and while they're
playing there's a running live chat with
all the people who follow them and
they're engaging with conversation with
those people they're reading the
comments those people are interacting
with each other with the streamer
there's some really interesting
subscription and incentive
infrastructure built in to allow people
to support creators and pay them and tip
them there's interesting incentives that
the creators and streamers can send back
down into the community to support their
loyal followers and what we've seen over
the past few years is not only are
people spending huge amounts of time on
this platform there are genuine
communities forming around these games
around these streamers that for the
moment don't have some of the same
problems that we're seeing in terms of
community formation and public
discussion and the you know bullying
issues trolls people coming in to poison
the dialogue for the moment that hasn't
really happened at twitch but at the
same time I think even though that's how
twitch has become the platform that it
is that's not what twitch sees as the
future of the platform it's always going
to be an important piece but twitch
itself wants to become the platform for
all live streaming for a whole variety
of communities from you know musicians
to people who right now are doing
beauty blogging on Instagram or YouTube
DIY politics Travel twitch wants to be
the place where anyone who has a who has
a use for live-streaming and wants to
build a community can come and make that
platform their home and so far we're
actually seeing some success there
there's been really interesting
experiments by the Washington Post and
news organization news organizations to
jump on the platform and create their
own streams amateur musicians are coming
on the platform and building their own
communities and finding ways to support
creation of their songs Nike and other
brands are coming on to the platform to
both support the e gamers and piggyback
off of the streams that they're doing
but also find new and interesting ways
to run their own streams on the platform
and as we get into the 2020 election
cycle I think there's going to be no
shortage of live events that are ripe
for streaming I think it's gonna be
really interesting to see if twitch can
have a breakout moment in the politics
and news space and not just the eSports
community and when they when that
happens I think you'll be interesting to
see can they actually deal with all of
the problems that we've seen on social
media that are inevitably gonna get
ported over to that platform as well so
what does this mean for Yale
start thinking about a live content
streaming strategy I'm sure you guys
have live streaming strategies you guys
do tons of events like this I'm sure
there's no shortage of streams happening
on own channels for Yale but what is
your live streaming channel strategy off
Yale channels what would you do if you
had to go and leverage something like
twitch in order to meet an audience
where they are and not expect them to
come to you I think over the next year
everyone should be watching twitch to
see what happens there's going to be so
many experiments on the platform by
brands by politicians it's going to be
really interesting to see where they can
break through and what takes off versus
you know is it gonna is it gonna just be
a blip and be purely relegated to this
eSports space and lastly as you think
about your strategy don't just think oh
I'm gonna go and create my own live
stream on Twitch there are lots of
interesting creators on the platform and
there's lots of ways
you piggyback off of those creators I
think one of the more interesting things
that I've seen is climate scientists
have actually been piggybacking on to
the livestream of gamers they'll get
into the they'll talk to you know
someone who has a following they'll play
a game like fortnight with them and they
will talk about climate change science
with the gamer while they're playing
fortnight so that they're able to reach
that broader community of people who are
used to playing with are used to
following that streamer number three
rise of the machine interfaces so I
think the big headline point here is
we're living through probably one of the
biggest changes in user interfaces in 30
years if you think back we had the
introduction of the graphical user
interface things were pretty static for
a long time
we got mobile mobile for the longest
time didn't even have its own native
formats we're just getting to that now
it was just really an of what we had
from desktops into a smaller screen but
now we're actually starting to see much
more native applications of you know how
we deal with them a mobile-first world
and I want to talk through a few of
those things a few of those interfaces
and what they mean but first I think
it's important to note that messaging
and one to one or one to few
Communications has started to overtake
social media so what you're seeing here
the big four messaging platforms back in
I think it was 2000 yeah 2015 crossed
over and have more daily users than the
social platforms and that is growing and
is probably going to keep growing this
is something that we see this is driven
well you know in many ways by Asia but
we in the West are starting to catch up
more and more and I think know where do
you see this more than in the way
Facebook is pivoting right now if you
think about all the things that they've
announced lately one of the most
significant is that they're going to
integrate whatsapp messenger and
Instagram on the back end to essentially
create one interoperable messaging
system and you know in part they're
doing that because those messaging
platform
our private and encrypted and if more
people are moving over towards messaging
platforms Facebook wants to be there and
if that can be in a private and
encrypted format Facebook doesn't have
to deal with all of the content
challenges that it has right now because
it can't see the content that's going
over those networks so if people are
bullying if there's misinformation
campaigns Facebook is technically unable
to even intervene in the way that a lot
of the policy discussions are happening
right now so that that's one reason you
know it's gonna solve the moderation
challenges they have but the other piece
is that they see the way that user
habits are changing they look at they
look at WeChat in in Asia and see how it
has become the one platform where
everything happens if you're a user of
WeChat in Asia you can use it to order
food you can get your car you can you
know order movie or plane tickets you
can shop you can chat with your friends
everything is plugged into the the
messaging system and everything
including commerce can happen through
that platform Facebook wants to be the
one that's in the position to be the
WeChat of the West and I think that's
also another reason you see them
starting to dip their toe into the
crypto space it would be great if they
could have their own currency within the
platform to help negotiate all of those
transactions but this is actually a big
problem for brands corporations
institutions like Yale we do not have as
advanced a messaging platform as they do
in Asia here and if you're trying to
reach people on these messaging
platforms it's really hard it is not
like a plug-and-play ad system or just
being able to get up organically and
hope people find you on the platform
those opportunities are not nearly as
robust and messaging here as they are in
Asia
so that is a that is a conundrum that a
lot of brands are gonna have to start
dealing with pivoting I promise this is
not a non-sequitur at the same time
we're seeing AI begin to transform whole
industries and sectors of the economy at
Weber shanwick we really looked at this
as an analytics opportunity first and
the chart that you see here from
McKinsey is actually sizing the
analytics opportunity of AI
and I know it's hard to read I'll spare
you the upshot is hundreds of billions
of dollars in potential value to be
unlocked through AI just in the analytic
space across industries but when you
think about marketing and communications
inclusive of but beyond analytics
McKinsey thinks there's a one to two
trillion dollar opportunity to be
unlocked there as well and that's
everything from ways that AI can assist
with better content personalization
upgrading service functions you know
there are lots of ways that AI can aid
in communications plans so why am I
talking about that and what is the
connection to messaging it's chatbots
the what we're seeing right now is that
AI driven chat bots are really the
initial touch point where these two
trends are coming together in a way
that's really impactful for our clients
so more and more consumers want to
interact with brands through messaging
systems they don't want to deal with
phone trees and terrible personal
customer service they don't want to go
and navigate websites where the logic
isn't constructed according to the way
that they want to interact with the
brand or how their questions need to be
answered they want a very simple system
where they can ask questions questions
can be answered and they can get to the
thing that they need to get to as fast
as possible and chat BOTS
particularly chat BOTS that are
leveraging natural language processing
and AI to understand intent and
sentiment and connect that back up to a
potential Bank of responses those are
the places where we're seeing really
successful engagements and and you know
a really successful application in
bringing AI and messaging together in a
way that solves solves that messaging
challenge in terms of how you how you
reach people through that type of a
platform and even the best chat bot is
still going to be for now at least
screen and text based but that is also
not the way that things are trending
overall when we think about user
interfaces so you know we're seeing more
and more people are interacting through
voice so right now more than half of the
US population actively uses
waste assistance either through their
phone or through a smart speaker in the
home
excuse me and this is starting to
radically alter both the search market
and the way people expect to interact
with technology and with brands so
comScore estimates that by next year 50%
of all searches are going to be done by
voice and Gartner says by the end of
next year
30% of all those searches are going to
be on a device that does not have a
screen at all
so that creates another another set of
challenges how do you if you think about
what a search strategy is how do you
make sure that when people are asking
questions to a voice assistant your
results are getting surfaced how do you
create applications that can reach and
engage people on those platforms we're
starting to see some interesting things
happen in that space so two in
particular that seem to be successful so
far is customer service people are we've
seen some companies particularly energy
utilities put together customer service
applications that can be activated by
voice on home speakers and walk you
through any problem that you're having
and they've also been using it for bill
pay so you know very common customer
interactions they're going out finding
new ways to get people through what can
often be frustrating processes faster
using new technology and so what does
that mean at Yale so I think it's a few
very disparate things actually so I'm
sure a lot of you are in charge of
social strategy for different functions
within Yale so how is your social
strategy going to evolve as audiences
stop using social and move over to
messaging what are you gonna do when
it's harder to reach them because the
platforms are less open less conducive
to mass communication and when we think
about leveraging AI chatbots
what are you doing on a regular basis
that can be routinized and automated
what are the frequently asked questions
that your department gets all of the
time that are either buried in web pages
or take an inordinate amount of time of
a real person's time to
rundown when they're getting them all
the time these are places where some
kind of automated solution like you know
a messaging a chat bot or a messaging
application can actually solve those
problems give you a better experience to
users and free up your staff time to do
you know more strategic things or take
the people who really need the
one-on-one help and go a lot deeper and
have a much higher level of that
personal customer service over fewer
interactions rather than spreading
themselves thin over a large number of
interactions and lastly how is your SEO
strategy going to evolve in when voice
captures more and more of the search
market it's not going to be about
optimizing around keywords it's you know
to the extent that you know your pages
are constructed correctly that always
helps but people are asking questions
right now they're asking questions about
the weather and news and sports but soon
they're gonna be asking questions about
everything and are you ready to get
served in you know the top result for a
particular question that is going to be
relevant to you as an institution and
the people that you want to talk with so
fake everything this one's probably
pretty self-explanatory
I think we've all seen the issues over
the past years so we have Russian BOTS
manipulating political conversations we
have BOTS and fraud on the ad side you
know we have the potential for deep
fakes to disrupt political conversation
or you know you know we are one deep
fake away from a company's bottom line
getting tanked and even you know the
desktop we saw around Nancy Pelosi just
a few weeks ago with the altered video
what people will call a cheap fake it's
not even a real deep fake it's just been
slightly altered can cause a huge amount
of problem and and you know we're even
seeing some interesting things happen
it's not all negative we're seeing some
interesting positive fake things
happening - like the growth of fate what
people are calling fake influencers but
are actually you know almost like
digital AI mascots for brands and these
are just a few
influencers that are not real but are
just as influential as many celebrities
are today so there's a lot going on in
that in this space I probably feels like
we've reached peak fake but I think it's
actually going to get a lot worse before
it gets better and that that's that's a
challenge for our clients and for
institutions you know in this
environment current listening solutions
are pretty inadequate you know for the
most part when you ask people how are
you monitoring what people are saying
how are you able to know whether
something is real or fake you know
people will tell you oh we're using
brand watch or you know we're using
Sysomos or Crimson hexagon and that's
great but are they going deep enough to
really understand what is happening and
where conversations are coming from
because conversations are not just
happening on Facebook and Twitter and
you know YouTube and Google there is a
whole whole other layers to the internet
and conversations are starting way down
deep hidden away from most people and
they are percolating up before they
before you see them go viral on the main
networks and and you know the challenges
by the time it gets to the main network
if you are a company that is you know
being if they're if you are a company
that is being attacked in some way if
you're a politician or a government
that's being attacked by the time it
gets to the main networks it's too late
all you can do is react you know you
have no chance of limiting the
conversation redefining the the
framework of the conversation you know
your ability to proactively dampen the
effect is already gone so the thing that
we're seeing companies do in response to
this is really level up there listening
capabilities and the way that they're
doing at is what we're calling media
forensics so it's a set of processes and
tools it's a combination of AI and
machines with human experts who can do
real research and understand what the
machines are uncovering and go into
places that the machine
can't actually go because if you
remember if you think back to all of the
different platforms on the iceberg and
that slide a lot of them have api's that
can be scraped by listening services a
lot of them don't a lot of them you have
to have a real person inside who
understands the cultures of the platform
investigating what's happening and we're
seeing companies bring these two things
together to start to understand you know
not just where things come from and how
they've spread but also as a warning
system that something may be coming and
they're going to need to have a response
to it in some way and you know just a
quick example of how this has worked in
the past
so everyone probably recognizes Emma
Gonzales the parkland activist so she
was on a Teen Vogue cover shoot with a
few of her fellow activists and she was
shown ripping up this this picture of a
gun of a gun target and way down in some
forums that that gun right advocates
congregate in they photoshopped the
target into a picture of the
Constitution they started to spread that
privately through their own networks it
started to percolate up into Reddit and
some other places that you know keep
that pulse that then took it up and
spread it into Twitter Facebook and
eventually it blew up and got on the
news so it's just an example of how that
and for how misinformation can percolate
through all of those levels and media
forensics is a way to you know if
necessary backtrack through those steps
and understand what happened or
hopefully proactively see it before it
breaks out and enable you to respond so
it is very much a crisis mitigation and
prevention tool but I think it also goes
beyond that so more and more consumers
are pushing companies to take stands on
social issues people want to be engaged
with companies that are active socially
and politically and this is this is
putting companies in a bit of a bind you
know there's lots of hashtags and memes
and things that are flying around on
social all of the time how do you know
whether something is right for you to
jump on to or not do you understand the
full provenance
an idea that is going viral on the web
and one of the best examples that I've
ever seen of this is this reporting by
the New York Times if you haven't read
it I highly recommend you go and find it
and take a look at it later today it
takes like 10 minutes to get through
it's not it's less intimidating than it
looks at time but what they did was took
a look at this phrase jobs not mobs and
they traced the evolution of it from
right-wing forums over onto Reddit where
it was picked up by Scott Adams the
cartoonist who created Dilbert
promoted on to his social channels
picked up by Fox News and then
eventually tweeted out by the President
of the United States so it you know
again it's about understanding the full
context of where something comes from
and how the conversations that we're
having as a society are developing so
that you can evaluate whether or not it
makes sense for you to be in that
conversation or not or at least have a
game plan for responding to that
conversation if it's something that's
directed at you as an organization and
so what it means that Yale I think this
is this is very much in line with what
we typically tell our clients so what
you know what is your monitoring
solution right now how deep does it go
what can it tell you what can it tell
you I think it's worth taking a moment
to understand what it's capable of and
what your need is for going deeper or
having a different solution than what
you have explore scenarios in which fake
content might damage your reputation
like I'm people who work in public
affairs or issues management positions
I'm sure you have an understanding of
you know places where Yale might be
perceived as vulnerable or at risk what
do those scenarios look like and then
how do you gameplan those out can you
conduct crisis training to make sure
that your response frameworks are
actually something that can workable and
are not going to fail you when the
moment to deploy them actually comes and
how do you create muscle memory among
staff who maybe are not familiar with
crisis management and you want them to
know how they're going to react in the
moment when something
this happens doing fantastic on time
this is great
so last one and this is this is a new
idea so you guys are my guinea pigs here
I have not presented this anywhere
before what I'm calling personal
ecosystems as the new executive equity
and if executive equity is to like
agency jargony of a term for you it
basically just means how do we promote
and raise the profile of executives
within an organization through PR
marketing advertising so I've mentioned
this before but there really is a strong
trend towards consumers wanting CEOs to
be engaged on social right now and CEO
starting to hop on social you know we're
seeing that consumers are more likely to
trust companies when they see that their
CEO is active on social and responding
to issues about the company or things
that are happening in the news we see
that employee engagement and
satisfaction is higher in companies
where CEOs are engaging in those ways
and and again consumers are more likely
to want to associate and make purchases
with companies that they feel are taking
a stand and where they see that active
engagement particularly from the c-suite
and all of this really points to over
the next year an influx of even more
CEOs and c-suite executives on social
media than are on there right now
particularly on the platforms like
Twitter Facebook and LinkedIn and
everyone will tell you you need to have
a strategy for that and you do and my
response is yeah but social is not
really the greatest places anymore you
know it's a bit of a dumpster fire and
you know is that where you want your CEO
to engage like do you want your CEO
exposed to all of the the craziness and
the people that are going to come out of
the woodwork and and attack it's not
really a conducive forum to complex
discussions as we as we found right now
and and the other thing is I think a lot
of executives who will naturally take to
the platform are probably earlier
ders and they're probably already there
so I do have my own doubts about whether
or not executives that are coming on
late to the game are going to be
comfortable in the medium and really put
themselves out there and say things that
are interesting enough to you know get
the kind of traction that they're hoping
to get but through a social program and
you know example number one of course is
Elon Musk so you know totally native
user of social has used it to
essentially be a one-man PR shop that
has vastly increased the reputation of
all of his companies but of late you
know we've literally seen him destroy
shareholder value with a tweet so a bit
of a cautionary tale as well and again
something that I think executives and
anyone who's charged with pulling
together an executive equity program
really needs to think about carefully at
the same time I am completely fascinated
by the emergence of slow media so I
think there's a really interesting
creative tension happening right now in
the media landscape so much is pushing
towards faster more snackable more
visual types of content all of the
advertising and monetary incentives of
the media system are aligned with
pushing for that faster type of content
and you know I think because of all the
challenges we're having with social
right now and relative lower trust in
the media people want to pull back from
that they don't necessarily want to
engage in all of those things as much as
they did in the past and I think we're
starting to see the development of media
systems that are tailored more towards
slower consumption deeper engagement on
individual topics and I think this is
why we're seeing newsletters have a
resurgence in popularity over the last
few years
they're both able to cut through the
clutter of all of the different things
that are coming in on your social feeds
and give you a curated view of what is
most important and a lot of the most
successful newsletters don't try and
boil the ocean and cover every
thing they go really deep on one topic
like Casey Newton's newsletter for The
Verge that specifically covers Facebook
and tech and privacy issues you know
there's a amazing blog slash newsletter
that is about business and tech called
Street a curry these are all made for
people who want to spend a lot more time
and thought on a particular topic and I
think nowhere are we seeing this more
than in the rise of podcasting as a
format so podcasting seems like it's
going to keep growing you know really
fast year over year the ad dollars are
starting to come there as well right now
which bodes well for the health of
podcasting as an overall media ecosystem
and as you can see from the chart here
the amount of time people are spending
with podcasts which is a very intimate
format that allows you to go really deep
really thoughtfully slowly on an
individual subject that's also you know
climbing really fast two hours per day
people are spending listening to
podcasts you know we're starting to get
into like TV territory in terms of how
much it's how much of your time it's
taking up and that's a really great
place for people who want to get
messages out there and the way that all
of this comes together is the personal
media ecosystem for Thought leadership
so I think what do I mean by this I
think the best example is just
journalists themselves journalists can
no longer afford to be you know employed
by you know one you know one news outlet
where they're writing one column or just
covering one beat they need to get
themselves out there in many different
formats because a it increases their
value to the news organizations and
helps them pull in more money but it's
also job security and you know helps
them find new jobs if the if the news
outlet that their act goes under or you
know cut staff they are able to build up
personal brands across multiple channels
that they're able to port with them
wherever they go and I think Dan Simmons
is a fantastic example of this he's
pretty much the master at it so Dan
Simmons for those who don't know is
his name in sports you know he has
founded a wide variety of media
platforms he has his own online magazine
called the ringer before that he had one
called Grantland he has his own podcast
he has livestream or he did livestream
his analysis of Game of Thrones after
every episode he has a Facebook live
that he puts on during sporting events
six million followers on Twitter 17
there's 177 thousand followers on
Instagram he's got columns on multiple
multiple publications Esquire recode you
had an HBO TV show for a while he has
extended his reach through multiple
channels and really built up a personal
brand and connection with a wide variety
of audiences that goes really deep on
each of those channels and I think this
is potentially a really interesting
model for thinking about executive
equity and thought leadership overall so
this is Carla B PhD I made her up she's
not real I tried to get an AI generated
fake person but the aspect ratios didn't
work out so she's a stock photo but you
can imagine that she is an employee at a
you know a biotech start-up in Boston
she you know knows a lot about biology
she knows about startups because she's
in a biotech she also cares deeply about
policy because how policy is implemented
directly affects her ability to do her
job you know if you are charged with
communications at the company that Carla
works at you could think about all of
the different ways you could raise her
put her profile and get her out there
you could be getting her on podcasts as
an expert tuner to be interviewed on you
know science podcasts women in tech
podcasts you could be cultivating her as
an expert source with The Wall Street
Journal on the business side she could
have her own Twitter following she could
be a contributor to a publication on
neuroscience that exists on medium
called the spike she could be writing a
series of
articles on Boston biotech on LinkedIn
and cultivating an audience there she
could be someone who appears on Facebook
live during company events and from a
paid perspective you know as you're
thinking about sponsored content on
podcasts or on newsletters she could be
a voice in in those in those channels
and so I think what's interesting here
is this is something that can be applied
not just to a CEO or not just to the
c-suite expertise and companies is not
just locked up in those few individuals
it exists throughout the organization
she doesn't have to be the primary
spokesperson that is there on every
channel all the time and in fact it's
better if she's not we have a we have
one client that I have worked on for a
while now where one of the challenges
they had is they have a bunch of
different departments all of who have
experts all of who get pitched to media
and because they all want the same media
they're constantly stepping over each
other's pitches and it's actually
working at cross-purposes with their
communication strategy and they're
essentially competing with themselves
for the same space in news articles if
all the experts had their own tailored
plan for where they were being pitched
what they how that was happening from an
own standpoint from an earn standpoint
from a paid standpoint I think the reach
of any one particular individual would
be smaller but you'd be able to build up
personal brands for all of these people
that run a lot deeper and you'll be able
to have a much more effective media
presence overall so what does it mean
for Yale I think you know first and
foremost the basics are school leaders
and spokespeople adequately represented
on social I stand by what I said about
social not necessarily always being the
best place but it is sort of a baseline
that people expect so then are you
taking advantage of slow media formats
and not to convey content that is
snackable but thinking about the
long-form really complex things you have
to convey and the way that those can be
vehicles for those types of
communications in a way that standard
social channels cannot and then if you
are responsible for promoting a wide
number of people maybe it's you know all
of the different faculty in a department
and their scholarship you know what is
the ecosystem strategy you could build
around each of those individuals that
want to work with you from a
communication standpoint to ensure that
they're all getting exposure they're all
getting the right level of effort
applied to their communications and
they're not stepping on each other
trying to you know secure the same spot
or talk to the same audiences and that's
it I think we've got some time for
questions
[Music]